colby's doing everything right brendan
in the last one week and i'm defining a
week by five days in the last five days
he has said i am the number one
contender and i have proven it he's
right he is the only guy ranked number
one in the whole sport that doesn't get
a fight for the championship he's in a
unique spot he already did twice against
the same guy history of the sport says
we don't go to number three if the
outcomes of one and two weren't split so
what does he do he comes up with an idea
he goes to a press conference says i'm
going to take this golden ticket i'm
going to cash it in against
dana white quite literally laughed okay
fine colby didn't get that one so next
time he's got a microphone in his hand
he goes after dustin poirier now dustin
poirier is not a 170 pounder but if you
do look at what colby did he called out
kamar guzman which he couldn't get he
called out assign it which got laughed
at he called out dustin before he was
not in the division those were three
hammers the one thing those three guys
have in common is world championship
belts colby is not asking for something
easy he just realizes i don't get what
every other number one contender gets i
don't get the title shot so give me all
something big and the one the one
takeaway that i did get from colby going
in three vastly different directions his
own weight class a weight class down in
a weight class up is that he sees what
you and i are talking about he sees he's
in a unique spot he's trying to make the
best he can with it but everybody's
telling him he's wrong he can't be wrong
non-stop even a broken clock is right
twice a day colby's just waiting for
something to come back and you want to
know who called colby covington out
between those three weight classes
nobody brendan they don't want to fight
the guy it means you're going to get a
main event it means you're going to get
a sold out arena it means you're going
to get a lot of really great things they
still don't want it yeah i think for
kobe he's in a tough spot again i would
watch kamar and kobe fight every
saturday i'd be happy with that take my
80 bucks i love that fight i think you
know colby
could make some changes maybe
you know get a win here or there against
camaro but kobe's your reigning champion
if he was just born five years before
five years later he's the best 170 on
the planet or not named kamar osman so
for colby
you know he he he shoots for the moon
hoping to land on the stars obviously
the izzy fights not happening um
i like his callouts i'm a huge fan of
colby i know you are too you're very
close with them but the dustin poured
and you could see even dana goes what
are we going to do with that
you know he's not even a true one seven
year you went you win that fight you're
still number one
i think as a purist and where he's going
to get some kind of backlash there is
there's some affordable you know i was
talking about before you came on there's
some really good 170 years coming up a
guy who i think kobe is going to have to
address very soon is hamzad i think
hamzad is the next big thing and i i do
see maybe the ufc forcing kobe's hand to
take that fight if he's going to stay at
170.
you